so welcome back today we are in
Washington DC at the World Bank and I am
particularly excited because we have as
our guest dish new Goss who's an
economist at the World Bank and dish new
has really been at the frontier of
thinking about and measuring healthcare
quality in low and middle income
countries just new thank you so much for
being here a pleasure to be here action
reporter so additionally let's get right
into it there is a lot of interest in
thinking about healthcare quality in
high-income countries there's been a lot
of work that's been done in the US and
England most of us feel like we know
less about the state of health care
quality in low-income countries or
middle-income countries what is the
state of health care quality in India I
think it's fair to say that the state of
health care quality in there is not good
and there are many many ways you can
talk about first of all the country is
bifurcated into right there's a better
performing self and the worst performing
North but I think you see that in every
health statistic that we have the second
part of it which I think is less known
is that that bifurcation carries over to
health care quality and you can think
about that in a couple of ways and the
one way I like to think about health
care quality is to just you know try and
see what happens when you as a patient
go to a doctor and then say how is
researchers can we mimic that experience
yes how can I tell you a little bit
above the average person who goes to the
doctor and what happens to them the
simplest way to think about it is to say
pick a condition that's really really
salient so for instance we have picked
chest pain in a middle-aged man which
usually in a place like the u.s. 98
percent of the times will be diagnosed
correctly and in the case we picked for
instance if the doctor had questioned
appropriately done the right exams he or
she would have diagnosed it as unstable
angina or what's in common parlance
called a heart attack so we train people
to
take these symptoms very very carefully
and send them to many many doctors and I
think the simplest way you could think
about poor health qualities you can ask
how many of these patients would receive
the right treatment and nothing else
that answer is about 5% so things get
slightly better when you say how many of
these guys would have received the right
treatment but would have also received
something else maybe the doctor did the
right thing but he also did a bunch of
things that were not totally correct so
that's about 40 to 45 percent but you're
still left with a majority of doctors
not being able to pick up diagnose or
treat a very expert case of chest pain
that appropriately diagnosed and treated
would lead into a heart attack
just so I understand what you're
describing you take standardized
patients people have been trained and
you send them off and about five percent
of the times the physician gets it right
and doesn't do anything else and a
majority of the times they don't even
get it right at all so what's going on
where is the failure are they not asking
the right questions are they not doing
the right exam what do we know about why
people have a hard time arriving at the
right diagnosis and treatment the first
failure could be that the doctor just
doesn't know right I mean the guy hasn't
been trained he doesn't have a medical
knowledge perhaps and if he doesn't know
that a chest pain could be oh how to act
maybe that's the biggest problem and in
fact if you read a lot of the literature
on health care a lot of it is about you
know the massive shortage of healthcare
workers or a staffing problem and we
don't have sufficiently trained doctors
the second part of it which i think is
less salient in the kind of health
policy world but hits us as patients
every day is that the doctor may not put
in enough effort right up so I don't
know how many you know how many people
have been to clinics in low-income
countries but unlike say clinics in the
u.s. where you're cordoned off from the
other patients there's a door you're
alone with the doctor the doctor listens
to you
a typical clinic that will work in if
you go in there are five people sitting
on the clinic these could be patients
might be other people might be friends
might be people from the community the
TV is blaring the patient comes in sits
the doctors talking on his cell phone
he'll pick up every call so it's an
extremely distracted environment there
various things going on and you want to
you know you want to start worrying
about is the doctor putting in enough
effort to look after you
yep right the third issue is sometimes
and this has been a worry especially
with with India and other countries
people think well maybe the doctors
getting paid to do something which they
know is not right or one way to think
about it and India is maybe they're
getting paid to ask you to get a bunch
of tests done because they're getting
kickbacks from probably industry